What I'm going to do first to deal with
this negative exponent factor is separate
it out from the rest of the factors. So
I'm just going to multiply a little bit
more explicitly. So you have 3m^2 times 1/n^-4.
However, we know that when we have a
negative exponent, n^4 in our case, these
factors actually equal to 1/n^4.
So I need to replace just the denominator
of this fraction right here with this
number. So that's going to give us
3m^2 times 1/1/n^4.
This is really not looking very pretty.
However, we know how to handle this.
Dividing by a fraction is the same as
multiplying by its reciprocal. So, for
example, we have 1 over a/b. That's just equal
to 1 times b/a.
So we can continue modifying this
expression using that trick. This is going
to equal, keeping the 3m^2, we keep the
numerator here, and we multiply by the
reciprocal of the denominator. So the
reciprocal of 1/n^4 is just n^4/1.
Well now this is easy. You know that
anything times 1 is just itself. And we
know anything divided by 1 is just itself.
So this leaves us with 3m^2n^4.
So again, we see that switching the sign
of an exponent, so switching from negative
4 to positive 4 here for the factor with
the n base. Just requires a flipping of
the exponent sign and a flipping of the
side of the equation that factors on. We
switch from having n^-4 in the denominator
to having n^4 in the numerator. If you
found working with fractions like this a
little bit difficult, not a big deal at
all. Just take some time to review
manipulation of fractions with the
materials that we've directed you to.